a camera is lowered down this well and
shows five-year-old rayanne alive but
unable to move he's been trapped since
tuesday rescue teams are giving him food
and water through pipes
i managed to communicate with the child
and asked if he could hear me there was
a response i waited for a minute and saw
that he began using the oxygen
the accident happened in the northern
moroccan village of igran
rescue teams say they can't widen the
well to reach him as it's too dangerous
so they're using diggers to strip away
the earth to the side of it it's an
agonizing wait for his family
when he disappeared i prayed to god and
i begged him to get him out of that well
alive and safe i pray to god to ease my
pain and his in that hole of dust
the rescue has gripped the nation and
beyond hashtag save ryan has been
trending on social media across north
africa
it's the fourth day that reyen has been
underground we're asking the authorities
to bring him out he's been down there
too long
rescue teams say they're close to
rescuing rayanne a police helicopter is
on standby to take him to hospital
victoria gatenby al jazeera